let me explain something really
interesting when the most people buy
property when they feel when they feel
confident or when they feel scared and
they feel confident when are most people
confident about the market when it's up
or when it's down up so what happens is
most people and then the bull would go
into an evolution this is what happens
properties go up and they go down and
they go up and they go down and they go
up and think I don't know said this
yesterday yes or no right so most people
buy when they're confident and then when
it dips they sell so because of this and
by the way when property prices were
really high it was around about 2007 and
then what happened in 2008 crashed and
then in London what happened in 2011
shot back up there's some parts of the
UK where houses today are cheaper than
they were in 2007 around 2005 2006 what
did the banks start doing 100% mortgages
they started giving out loads and loads
and loads of money what's the cause of
what's one of the causes for recessions
the banks were like money that's what
happened in 2007 the banks were given
out so much money they ran out of money
and they couldn't lend anymore and what
happened it was because they couldn't
lend any more people suddenly couldn't
get mortgages and because they couldn't
get mortgages they couldn't buy
properties and because they couldn't buy
properties properties weren't able to
sell and the price is dropped and that's
why properties crashed however in 2011
they started giving out money again so
what happened as the prices went back up
but there's still parts of the of
England where they haven't picked up
yeah like Liverpool for instance
Liverpool is only just picking up now
and it's going crazy
Manchester only picked up three years
ago now it's going crazy but
Middlesbrough doesn't know yet
Middlesbrough still asleep so that's
what caused recession the the other
reason that causes a recession is that
the people run out of money
so sometimes when there's a lot of
unemployment or if everyone loses their
jobs well there's too much bad debt
going on and bother a bad day tink
it's bothered by the system by the way
bad days encouraged by the system which
freaks me out
so they accuse me of encouraging death
Oh Samuel Lee's encourage people to go
in today I'm like - right I don't if
they understand the difference between
good debt and bad debt but you system
encourage people to get into bad debt
and say no we don't yeah you do
because if I go to the bank and say can
I have a loan please for a house that I
found at the crash course they'll say
it's too risky
but if I say can have a loan please to
go on holiday or to get married they'll
say approved that's just the facts so
why would it back happily give you money
to go on holiday but they won't give you
money to invest because they want you to
be poor because they want you to go into
debt so that you'd be a slave to the
system and continue working in a job
until you're 67 and then retire on 40%
of what you couldn't afford to live on
in the first place even after working
for years before tea hours a week that's
the system you know so that's that's the
other reason for recession the people
can't go any money the third reason for
recession is because of the fear of one
of the above and what happened in the
last couple years it's been a lot of
fear because of brexit and still have
been fear but right now there's places
that are so cheap like Middlesbrough
where else where where is cheaper now
than it was but like Paul correct where
else
Bradford yeah correct where else Grimsby
correct Liverpool is correct he's going
up at the moment
Hartlepool correct partly Paul where
else Durham there's a lot of places now
this is that why am I telling you this
how is this gonna benefit you in any way
I'm gonna explain something right now
which we again don't always say at the
crash course is but I just want you guys
to go and kick some ass I'm gonna say it
I want you to do it are you ready yes or
no are you sure yes or no
all right these places are cheaper today
than they were in 2007 and in 2006 the
banks were giving 100% mortgages so
right now there are people selling their
house for cheaper and they're in
negative equity now let me explain what
negative equity means
equity simply means that the value of
the house is less than the outstanding
mortgage if the value of the house is a
hundred grand and the mortgage is 102
grams they cannot sell the house they're
in negative equity they can't drop the
price because if they drop the price of
the house then they're not gonna have to
pay off the mortgage their what we
called stuck now when they are stuck
what we do is we offer a lease option
agreement at least option agreement is
when you buy a property now so you buy
it today but you don't pay for it for
some time down the line which is agreed
between you and the seller that could be
3 years 5 years 7 years 10 years now why
is lease option agreement so genius the
reason is is because if you buy it now
but pay for it in 10 years well on
average properties double in value every
10 years by the time you come to
actually have to pay for it it's doubled
in value on top of that in the 10 years
not only if you gain from all the
appreciation of the property but you've
also benefited from the monthly cash
flow because you buy it and become the
landlord as if you own it today but
don't pay for it for 10 years how do you
find people to pass you their property
on a lease option agreement you find
motivated sellers and tired landlords
that just their properties are burden
for them but for you it's an asset
because you are a property investor on
the property investors crash course we
literally find live properties and
sellers for people who would be suited
to do a lease option agreement but you
won't come because you're a loser
probably sounds harsh but only 1% of
people that watch these videos actually
take action so prove me wrong don't be a
loser don't be a [ __ ] to someone else
working for a job forever you can take
yourself out the game and say I've gotta
go I don't got the money or oh no no no
just take action come and meet me at the
property investors crash course believe
me after me
in me for two days you are Amy friggin
excuses so what happened next day after
the kruskal's i saw i changed my
strategy and i started looking at lease
options i started looking at HMOs I
bought HMO straight after that crash
course in Stoke yeah and then I realized
my strategy was probably lease options
was better for me cuz didn't evolve that
big chunk of cash up front yeah and I
found that I could do that easy getting
vented straightaway and once you know
how to do a lease option I studied in
Warren and which he can do you know from
casual a 250-pound the advantages to buy
multiple together and as you know
landlords are looking at getting out
yeah well no G Caitlin was again very
educated because of section 24 yeah BEC
sir yeah it's a bit of uncertainty they
don't know what to do
so landlords are something up so there's
a bit of a niche there to buy portfolios
on delete options and so I've sort of
switched strategy instead of buy one I
have nobody took multiple love that so
clever rather than trying to fight
because it cuz also it's the same amount
of work to fall in one vendor or and buy
warm property lease option with it is to
buy for 10 minutes on absolutely so
that's really neat so I did a few single
ones than I did two as a portfolio which
is quite easy yeah almost a feeling the
node it sorry and the deliver so so the
one in Telford is a portfolio of 11 yeah
so we could either there's two ways we
could do it we could even set a price
now I'm size for instance seventy
thousand pounds and give the market
chance to recover or we could we could
we could say a percentage of what its
gonna buy depending on what you know you
felt more comfortable with so we could
just set an agreed figure inside in in
say three years time we'll buy it for 70
and we'll give you 250 pounds per month
guaranteed until the end of the three
years but of course it's all negotiable
and in the same way as you do obviously
have to think about it and see what the
response was from the advert odd of
course have to see the property and and
things like that I'm not making you an
official offer I'm just letting you know
the the outline of what it could look
like that make sense if it passive
income is you is your goal in just one
easy life
then maybe I could offer you something
like this so I can give you a fair rent
based on what you you pay in every
single month for the for the property
yourself
and with that I'd take over the
management the tenants any any
maintenance repairs anything like that
give you a fair rent but give you the
asking price that you want a little bit
more
they had a period of time so you said
you had 130,000 forever filly after the
property so maybe maybe I could give you
140,000 but in seven years time just to
give the time for the market to recover
but in a period I'll give you a fair
rent and a fair fee every single month
no no I can manage it I can maintain it
and I can look after all the tenants you
don't have to worry about it completely
hands-off how does something like that
sound to that you would sort all the
tenants and they were management yeah
mate and some the property and yell for
I'll pay six seven five months how much
is your insurance I'll pay that as well
so we're six nine seven yeah I'll pay
for you solicitors fees as well yeah so
that everything because basically I need
you to be protected underneath I want
useful comfortably because if we're
going to be working together for seven
years and then have to be nice to be
obviously I need to know each other and
get on with each other absolutely nice
way and it's all about transparency so
out of about a goodwill gesture
I'll cover the the solicitors I'll cover
the the rent and I'll do the building
assurance so basically you're gonna say
yeah effectively yeah and you'll be his
hunter and pretending that seven years
you've got the right to exercise the
options yeah for at 440,000 anything
goes up in value you're trying to make
money yeah you wanna make money but you
want a peaceful life yeah okay okay you
need to speak to the owner you need to
tell him we'll pay him 200 bucks a month
will bite the 75,000 pounds in five
years I'll give you all the contracts
and stuff to do that
which he can sign
I'll also send you another memorandum of
understanding which we can sign which is
what I basically just told you like the
bullet points of this conversation and
the agreement and you can sign it will
sign it then you get that if you can get
the seller on board you be sure you
should be making at least three four
hundred bucks a month and just just for
managing it Dale man dude you're
freaking awesome awesome that's just one
way how you can make money in a
recession Lease Option agreements but
there's also many ways 2020 honestly
there are many many opportunities so I'd
like to see you at the property
investors crash course get yourself
booked on completely free on the house
on me no CAPTCHAs get booked on right
here you know what you're watching this
video for a reason so click on book on
right now I'll see you there what are
you waiting for get [ __ ] up get [ __ ]
on give up time I'll see you there